anflug auf jakutien im nordosten
sibiriens
ich sehe viel wasser hoffentlich nicht
zu viel für unseren abenteuer
vielleicht schafft man es bis zur hälfte
der strecke und bleibt einstecken
wegen des hochwassers weil es so viel
regnet dann muss man warten bis das
wasser wieder senken müssen da kommst du
nicht mehr vorwärts nicht mehr rückwärts
mein name ist christof franzen
ich war elf jahre russland korrespondent
des schweizer fernsehens in dieser
abgelegenen gegend sibiriens reist ich
bereits im jahre 2011 eine der schönsten
reisen meiner korrespondenten zeigt
damals porträtierte ich den nomaden
jungen christa vor und erlebte
geschichten die mir bis heute in
erinnerung geblieben sind
eine davon ist der versuch ein
neugeborenes kind hier zu retten
die mutter wollte es nicht sorgen
[Musik]
die hauptsache ist dass das kleine
endlich zu saugen anfängt
ja es sagt ein kleines bisschen eine
kindheit im einklang mit der tiger mit
viel freiheit aber auch schon große
verantwortung
meine korrespondenten zeit in russland
geht bald zu ende
mir war immer klar an diesen ort möchte
ich noch einmal zurückkehrt geht es
christa vor heute ist das leben dort
noch immer so hoch spryng lich wie
meiner erinnerung
[Musik]
da hast du das nicht das ist mein
regisseur tate dir ist russland green
hohen und neugierig auf die lilien
ich hoffe er weiß auf was sie sich
eingelassen hat
letztes mal reißt dich bequem per
helikopter
jetzt wollen wir dieses extreme gebiet
so erleben wie die einheimischen über
land und ungefiltert mein treuer
kameramann china wird die expedition in
den russischen fernen osten für die
nachwelt festhalten
der mann im blauen jackett ist slawa
unser einheimischer guide
wer hätte uns ruhig sagen können dass
das abenteuer bereits auf dem parkplatz
beginnt
[Musik]
das ist noch gar nicht dort
tiger gibt es viele davon die gleichen
insekten
[Musik]
wir befinden uns in jakutsk 5000 km
östlich von moskau
von hier fahren wir 1000 kilometer auf
einer der angeblich gefaehrlichsten
strassen der welt bis ost nähe von
unserem zielort so soll ein lkw kommen
der uns dort abholt dann geht s 200 km
durch absolute wildnis nach asyl und
nochmal 50 km weiter zu den tieren
nomaden und den jungen christa vor
[Musik]
fahrer sergej songs bis näher bringen
doch wir wissen nicht ob wir von dort
überhaupt weit kommen die wolken am
himmel verheißen nichts gutes
[Musik]
wie ist die situation brauche ich das
wasser kommt der truck ist noch nicht
losgefahren oder nein noch nicht
wir sind unterwegs auf der calima roth
der einzigen straße welche die städte
magadan jakobus nehrer verbindet
die straße wird auch straße der knochen
oder straße des todes genannt weil sie
von colak häftlingen erbaut wurde
dass sie wussten es hat gold braucht die
straße da braucht es im illegalen gulag
so wurden straflager zu stalin zeit
genannt
darin kamen millionen menschen ums leben
allein entlang diese 2000 kilometer
langen straße gab es 800 1000 gefangenen
tausende starten
jako 10 ist die größte region sibiriens
und die kälteste bewohnte region der
erde
im winter wird es hier kälter als minus
60 grad im winter ist es schwer einen
toten zu begraben muss man die erde oft
als die straße gebaut wurde hat man die
gleichen einfachen den entstandenen
krage geworfen
wir weichen das ostsibirische bergland
[Musik]
ein vorgeschmack auf das ziel unserer
reise wunderschön arbeit gefährlich
das desaster
gehört
große eingeschlafen ist hilft der
rettungsdienst
woher soll hier ein rettungsdienst
kommen zu essen habe ich er hat mir
einen zettel mit handynummer gegeben die
ich anrufen sollen wir haben ein
satelliten-telefon ruft doch gleich
jetzt an
ich bin in den graben gefahren
eingeschlafen da ich schon eine ganz zu
sein
also will das in russland ums leben
kommt verstoßen
2220 1027
seine retter sind 1000 kilometer
entfernt das bedeutet auf dieser straße
mindestens zwei tage
[Musik]
die calima rot gilt als eine der
gefährlichsten straßen der welt sogar
reifentests werden hier durchgeführt
auch wir merken schnell einmal wie
heimtückisch sie sein kann
[Musik]
die rohre unter der straße kolde störung
nicht standhalten das hat sie
weggeschwemmt jetzt versuchen wir eine
durchfahrt zu machen
das hängt alles davon ab wie schnell das
wasser sinkt der schneller desto besser
kommen wir voran
jeder fuß ist einmalig haben sich sehen
wie tief ist wir schütten es rein es
wird wieder weggeschwemmt dann bleibt
die tiefe genau gleich gibt es eine
alternative das zu haben nein dort sieht
es noch schlimmer aus
das passiert jedes jahr einige orte sind
schwach man müsste sie verstärken
dafür bräuchte man geld jetzt brauchen
die brücke vom festland krim er dort
wird die brücke gebaut
hier haben wir einen dreck solche
brücken
[Musik]
im besten fall also den ganzen tag
warten zumindest hat das wasser den
höchststand wohl hinter sich
[Musik]
für unsere mit wartenden scheint die
situation nicht so außergewöhnlich zu
sein
[Musik]
zeit wird in jakutien mit anderen
maßstäben gemessen
das spürte ich schon bei meinem letzten
besuch passiert ist ein 700 einwohner
dorf im umkreis von 200 kilometern
nichts dass tiger berge und flüsse
hier gehen die kinder herdentier nomaden
zur schule und verbringen geschlagene
neun monate im jahr getrennt von ihren
familien und ihren rentierherden davor
lebte werden der schulzeit dem haus
seiner cousine hier dem dorf erlebte ich
ihnen wie ausgewechselt
kaum 20 worte sprach er werden des
gesamten drews mit mir
ich begleitete ihn in die schule die er
nicht besonders mochte beim sätze bilden
wurde mir klar wohl mit seinen gedanken
war
sobald die schule zu ende ist 30 sofort
zu meinen rentieren
[Musik]
wir sind näher
wir wollen von ost nähe danach passiert
wir haben vielleicht einen fahrer
wir sind die wege das wasser steht hoch
es scheint sogar noch gestiegen zu sein
mit zwei tagen verspätung haben wir dann
doch noch die goldgräberstadt mehr
erreicht mündung der newa bedeutet
dieser name und die nähe zeigt uns
deutlich immer noch hochwasser die
verspätung ist egal
der lastwagen aus d'azur der uns
eigentlich abholen sollte ist gar nicht
erst losgefahren
unsere letzte hoffnung ist was viele
auch ein fahrer aus dass der hier
zusammen mit seinen passagieren
angeblich schon seit zwei wochen
festsitzt
wir waren schon mal installiert zum
filmen vor sechs jahren in der schule
und so jetzt wollen wir wieder dorthin
mit ihnen unser auto mit dem fahrwerk
er hat noch platz für eine kleine
wohnung wieder also wenn du sagst es
kommen noch zwölf sonst mit ein bisschen
naja das ist den aufführungen auch
können sodass kein luxus gewesen
wie lange brauchen wir uns auf die
strecke hier für euch
die habe ich als einem verlassenen haus
geholt damit er es bequem haben das ziel
ist dass zum schutz
das ist für die jagd
[Musik]
was du nicht viel
die wenn du noch wie sie möchte
seien wir unserem brot für besteck
zugegeben jetzt will ich liebe in diesem
flugzeug
doch es ist schon eine einmalige
gelegenheit eine solche reise kann man
nicht planen
[Musik]
slava versucht und sind regisseur etwas
aufzumuntern
ich will sich schöne natur sehen deshalb
mache ich diese reise
es ist ein langer und schwieriger weg
über exzellente natur
etliches zumindest das
[Musik]
doch die natur zeigt sich erst einmal
von ihrer unendlichen seite schon der
erste floss denn überqueren müssen führt
hochwasser
ein versuch die götter milde zu stimmen
scheint momentan die einzige idee zu
sein
wie sieht's aus vassili
wir überlegen wie wir darüber kommen
die zivilisation liegt hinter uns wenn
das wasser zurückgeht fahren wir sonst
heißt es warten
egal wie lange
unsere reisegefährten sind erwähnen wie
die rentier nomaden eine volksgruppe von
weniger als 20.000 menschen mit eigener
sprache
jeder von ihnen scheint genau zu wissen
wo er anpacken muss
[Musik]
es gibt hier
nachts sind hier selbst im sommer kalte
0 grad
wir sind so weit im norden dass es nur
noch für knapp zwei stunden richtig
dunkel wird im morgengrauen wird
schmerzhaft deutlich was noch vor uns
liegt
von atemberaubender natur sind wir noch
weit entfernt
wir haben goldgräber gewütet
auch nach der kurzen nacht keine
wesentliche veränderung
weiterfahrt immer noch unmöglich
[Musik]
siehst du das fahrerhäuschen dahinten
das im lastwagen umgekippt
den hat es ja ganz ungetrübt
ein oral wie unsere und die leute haben
sie es geschafft
sie konnten rechtzeitig springen es ist
sehr gefährlich
keine leichte entscheidung wurde wir
müssen gut nach dem jungen zu viele
leute die kinder ausländer
das wäre ein skandal ein internationaler
der hat es wieder geschafft
er sagt wenn diese hier vorbei ist das
schlimmste
in dieser meinte das eigentliche
theoretisch am meisten wasser sein
müsste weil dieser fluss teil selbst
wenn wir kippten sollen wir springen
aber in welche richtung
h
ich muss mich gegengewichten
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht wie viele schläge das
jetzt noch ausgehalten hätten
vielleicht habe ich meine runden kilo
genau wie hier gerettet
[Musik]
leider war die prognose was die
abnehmende tiefe der flüsse angeht total
daneben
[Musik]
so geht es dahin
stunde um stunde plus um fluss unsere
arche dich nach abgasen und menschlichem
unsere mitreisenden nehmen es mit
stoischer gelassenheit
selbst die kinder beklagen sich nehmen
[Musik]
wie heißen sie manchmal drei tage
manchmal sehen
zehn tage einmal sind wir im winter bei
minus 50 grad gefallen
dann ist uns das lenkrad eingefroren wir
mussten es mit dem gasbrenner wieder
auftauen
golan ist biologie studentin in jakutsk
und fährt zweimal im jahr heim nach saß
ihr ich könnte mir so eine reise bei
minus 50 grad nicht vorstellen dass
folgte moos fühlt sich schon jetzt
bitter kalt an
selbst im kurzen sommer ist der boden
hier wenige meter unter der oberfläche
gefroren
[Musik]
doch der nächste tag bringt eine
überraschung
[Musik]
ähnliche in freier natur
der hängt
die nervöse unruhe auf der ladefläche
macht es nicht gerade einfach zu zielen
[Musik]
gegen glück der angeschossene ehrlich
flieht ausgerechnet über die einzige
schneefläche weit und breit
was sind vassili
nehmen sie das ganze fleisch mit das
fleisch bei uns mit dass sein neuer
passagier
was fühlen sie wenn sie das sehen
es tut mir schon leid aber es wäre eine
sünde sich zu beschweren
man sollte dankbar sein das ist ein
geschenk der natur
was bedeutet das tier füße das ist
zusätzliches fleisch im sommer essen wie
oft nur dosenfleisch das ist
frischfleisch eine frage was ist denn
ihr lieblingsstück
suppe aus den rippen und gen ihren
gebraten sibirische social die leber
verzehrt man am besten frisch wir werden
nicht eingeladen
und das ist gut so
sein eindruck dass wilde sibirien mit
dem partner hoffentlich nicht mehr so
wiesen trotz allem beeindruckend wie
frauen männer und kinder genau wissen
was zu tun ist
was für ein erlebnis jetzt werde eine
dusche nicht schlecht
trotz
eigentlich ganz unterhaltsam würden wir
nicht geschlagene sechs stunden mit
einem elch unter diesem dach verbringen
[Musik]
jeden schönen moment in sibirien muss
man sich hart erarbeiten
[Musik]
an besonderen orten haben schamanen
opfer stellen eingerichtet
hier ist außerdem das tor zum
nationalpark moma
[Musik]
hier und hier ist dann direkt hierher
das ist schön aber sehr abgelegen etwas
weit die jungen ziehen weg sie machen
ausbildungen in der stadt
sie haben fünf kindern der mittlere sagt
der achten klasse konnte zu meiner herde
wir lassen sie an der stadt zum
studieren vielleicht sollte ich sie
nicht gehen lassen
hier ist es doch viel besser nächste
herausforderung
wie sieht's aus
wir müssen aus den koffern
könnten wir über das eis farben werden
wir viel schneller
doch wir haben sowieso längst jegliches
gefühl für zeit verloren was mir
christoph aus der schweiz zunehmend als
tortur erscheint war für den nomaden
jungen christa vor damals der schönste
tag des jahres
[Musik]
nach neun monaten schule in sassia
durfte er im frühjahr endlich zu seiner
herde reisen
eine fahrt die selbst für den vater
victor mit seinem wsj eine
herausforderung war nach über zwölf
stunden musste noch ein letzter pass
bezwungen werden
charmant hinten dann kam endlich der
moment auf den christa vor so lange
gewartet hatte das wiedersehen mit
seiner familie zuerst grüßte ihn sein
vater dimitri dann seine mutter
katherine
selbst bei den zurückhaltenden erwähnen
konnte ich die freude hier und da spüren
noch motivieren
umso mehr jetzt erst recht
der wettergott war mit uns nach vier
tagen erreichen wir saßen
alles zuerst verlässt uns die
mittlerweile nüchterne familie und wie
war die reise wir sie daran gewöhnt wir
reisen oft weil es die nächste reise
kann mir auch schon morgen saß er ist
einer der entlegensten orte die ich mir
vorstellen kann das ende des
riesenreiches russland der hand der
zivilisation schon als kind schaut ich
reise serien im fernsehen und träumte
davon so etwas eines tages auch zu leben
[Musik]
bei meinem ersten besuch und auch heute
fühlt es sich an wie jetzt bist du
angekommen
[Musik]
leider ist hier nicht das ziel unserer
reise und wir haben ein problem
wir wollen zu den tieren nomaden in den
bergen
die einzige möglichkeit dorthin zu
kommen ist mein alter bekannter viktor
mit seinem wie es die rot doch man sagte
uns er sei krank und fade nicht mehr
hallo herr denen sie sich an mich
natürlich hatte ich saß er wieder
ja es ist wie ein sohn für einen nicht
mehr loslässt möchtet ihr wieder zu den
rentieren
das hängt jetzt von ihnen ab fahren sie
nicht mehr es gibt das gerücht man könne
sie nicht mehr da zu überleben
das ging um diese geologen jetzt habe
ich gar nicht gefragt wie es ihnen geht
ich will nicht sagen
im winter hatte ich drei operationen
aber im sommer arbeite ich jetzt aus
gold jährlich mit erfolg in den bergen
gibt es überall gold viktor verbringt
den ganzen sommer in den bergen und er
sei gesund genug um wie es die rot zu
fahren
die geologen hat er aus einem anderen
grund nicht transportiert im dorf geht
die angst um die großen gold unternehmen
könnten kommen und dass ihr ausradieren
es wird sogar von einer initiative
gesprochen die das dorf als unesco
kulturerbe schützen lassen will
noch eine letzte tagesreise liegt vor
uns wir wissen mittlerweile was das
bedeuten kann
und schon kurz nach der müllkippe haben
wir das gefühl unsere gäste rot könnte
schrottreif sein
[Musik]
und schon das nächste problem wir sind
hinten so leicht um in diesem sumpf
voranzukommen
noch mal kurz die kette flicken dann
besorgen wir den nötigen ballast
[Musik]
[Applaus]
victor ist der typ wortkarger tiger kind
ist tot
gibt es ein problem denkt dem stillen
nach und dann macht er garantiert etwas
krasses
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
nach elf stunden haben wir zumindest die
berge erreicht
[Musik]
das schön zu wissen dass es noch gibt
die zeit der gewählt relativ richtig ist
läuft auch nicht
wirklich zeigen
weil einfach nicht weiß was geschehen
die socceroos geführt
[Musik]
ich weiß ja die moderne hat auch so
siehr und die nomaden längst eingeholt
schon vor sechs jahren kam gerade der
erste internet anschluss ins dorf ob
christa vor wohl immer noch so
heimatverbunden ist oder folgt auch der
nomaden jung mit dem ruf der stadt
[Musik]
die antwort
wie geht's euch gut unser sohn ist
erwachsen geworden ist alles drin sind
die echt kommen sie rein ihnen nicht
sicher galt ja wir sind 13 stunden
gefahren
in welcher klasse warst du damals in der
fünften mal bist du jetzt 17
ich erfahre dass chris davor auch heute
nur im sommer bei den orientieren und
seine familie lebt der wohnt in der
stadt jakutsk macht dort eine ausbildung
als baggerfahrer jetzt noch ein jahr
dann kann ich wirklich wieso ich will
selbst dort wo sie mich nehmen
nach der armee bekommt man leichter eine
arbeit wie gefällt dir denn der stadt
ganz okay ich habe mich daran gewöhnt
christa vor ist immer noch so wortkarg
wie damals er ist wohl eher ein
wanderpfad die den morgen werden die
rentiere von in weiden in den bergen ins
lager geholt
die rentiere ernähren sich von diesem
kraut das jagel heißt eine woche dauert
es bis die weiten abgefressen sind dann
sieht das gesamte lager erweitert
das ankommen der herde war schon letztes
mal ein erlebnis für mich
[Musik]
rund 900 christophorus familie
die nomaden produzieren fleisch und fett
der export von hier ist allerdings
schwierig sie leben hauptsächlich von
staatlichen subventionen
heute ist medizin tag verletzte oder
kranke tiere müssen eingefangen werden
um sie behandeln zu können
christa vor scheint ganz in seinem
element dennoch konnte er sich noch
nicht entscheiden ob seine zukunft in
der stadt oder bei den tieren liegt was
fehlt dir wenn du in jakutsk ist das
habe ich doch gestern schon gesagt die
berge die natur
[Musik]
wir werden die rentiere auch vermessen
sie sind extrem zutraulich und sie
lieben salz
christa voß eltern haben erkannt welch
positiven effekt der kontakt mit diesen
tieren haben kann
seit 20 jahren laden sie waisenkinder
oder kinder aus problemfamilien dazu ein
den sommerlichen zu verbringen
[Musik]
den kindern den aufenthalt sichtlich gut
bist du denn gewinne
[Musik]
unser ziel war dass die kinder
rentierzüchter bleiben wollen wir
mussten feststellen dass die jungen das
nicht vor
die kinder im sommer hier waren werden
erwachsen die armee oder heiraten
manche machen eine ausbildung in den
ferien kommen sie gerne sie erinnern
sich manchmal rufen an
das freut uns leider ist unser
aufenthalt wegen der langen anreise viel
zu kurz allzu viele worte hat christa
vor auch bei diesem treffen nicht mit
mir gesprochen
doch wir verabreden über facebook in
kontakt zu bleiben
junge den tierzüchter gehen mit der zeit
ich bin wieder beeindruckt wie
warmherzig wie hier empfangen worden
irgendetwas scheint dieser ort mit mir
zu machen
ich glaube meinen begleiten geht es ganz
ähnlich
[Musik]
das ist nur der wind
wieder so ein moment der mir noch lange
im gedächtnis bleiben wird
und ich stelle mir schon die frage wie
lange wird es hier noch so sein und
werde ich wohl jemals zurückkommen
[Musik]
ein schöner moment aber irgendwie auch
ein trauriges
in der nächsten folge bin ich in der
russischen kulturhauptstadt sankt
petersburg mit einer ganz besonderen
herausforderung zum abschluss meiner
korrespondenten zeit abseits der politik
ich will in einem russischen orthodoxen
chor mitsingen
der bekannte kirchenchor der isaaks
kathedrale lädt mich zum casting ein